لاستخدام ذراعها بشكل شبهي طبيعي بعدما
كسرت بحادثه دخلت على اثرها المستشفى قبل
اشهر تلقت الرعايه اللازمه لكن تجربتها لم
تكن جيده
كنت محظوظه لانني اجريت العمليه بعد ايام
فقط من الحادثه لكن ما رايته في المستشفى
كان مروعا فالممرضون كانوا تحت ضغط شديد
للغايه مهما تراكم اعداد المرضى والكل كان
مستعجلا لم تكن تجربه جيده
من ازدحام في اقسام الطوارئ يعيشه كل يوم
الممرضون والاطباء ومنهم اندرو الذي يعتقد
ان ما يحدث في المستشفيات لا يليق بخامس
اغنى دوله في العالم
محبط ما نراه من ضغوط في قسم الطوارئ
الدوام الجيد بالنسبه الينا هو الذي لا
يموت خلاله مريض في غرفه الانتظار او في
سياره اسعاف متاخره خلال عقد من التقشف
توفي 350 الف شخص بينما يموت 500 مريض
اسبوعيا
وقد ادى تقليص ميزانيه الصحه في ظل حكومه
المحافظين الى تراجع جوده الرعايه الصحيه
ولم يعد هناك ما يكفي من الكوادر لعلاج
اعداد المرضى المتناميه
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني تعهد بتخفيف
الضغوط على المستشفيات بخطه مقدارها نصف
مليار حتى يرون ان الازمه لا تنحصر في ضعف
التمويل فحسب
هذا حل قصير الاجل لان زياده عدد الاسره
يحتاج الى زياده الكوادر الطبيه وحتى ان
وجدت فان هذه الاسره ستمتلئ خلال اسابيع
لذلك فنحن بحاجه الى ايجاد حل لتتبع
المرضى في بيوتهم ويخشى بعض البريطانيين
من قيام الحكومه بخصخصه خدمه الصحه لاسيما
مع ارتفاع الدين القومي لمستويات قياسيه
اظهر استطلاع للراي ان اكثر من 50% من
البريطانيين يحملون الحكومه مسؤوليه ترد
الخدمات الصحيه نتيجه يرى كثير منهم انها
تلقي على كاهن الحكومه التزاما باعاده
تاهيل القطاع الصحي الذي يكتسي اهميه
كبيره بالنسبه للبريطانيين خصوصا ذوي
الدخل المحدود منهم من حرب الجزيره لندن